goo
[拍手]
さあ皆さんへこんにちは
今日は地元松江でね今紹介あたりモルツれるという会社を経営しているのと申します
去年僕が皆さんにこう伝えをしていきたいということはですね
ガッチャンコが日本を救うっていうねちょっと面白いでしょ
こういうお話をしたいと思っています現在 a 僕のビジネスそしてへライフワークは
社会課題解決
いわゆるソーシャルビジネスとかっていうのがね言われますけどまぁそういったものを
テーマにしていばやっています
その現場今ゴリゴリ動かしてますソーシャルビジネスをですね
動かしている現場そこで実践している中で
a と b というねまったくねー
異質でまぁこれまで融合したことがない
そんなものですねガッチャンコする
合わせていくことで課題解決というものができる
そんな風に確信ができたのでそんな話を中心に今日はお話したいと思います
僕の
創業は平成8年ちょうど猫の島根大学のすぐ近くにあります
大手フランチャイズチェーンのお弁当屋さんでした
当時ね
僕は20代でしたんで
まあ通すや儲かるんやろうってね
そんなことばっかり考えていました
当時フランチャイズの店舗は持ち帰り弁当の専門店だったんですね
も近いの専門店ですでも僕は
プランチャールールを破って
日本で初めて温かいお弁当の宅配サービスを展開し始めるんです
宅配サービスをすると
あることにね気がつくわけです
玄関口を開けてもらえればそのうちのことが
丸見えなんですね
例えば玄関口25センチくらいの小さい赤い靴が置いてあればここには小学校上がる前
くらいの女の子がいるって事は間違いなくわかりますよね
すかさず僕たちはあセールスするんですね運動会のお弁当
いかがですかってね
お客さんの来店お待ち続ける商売から
積極的にお客さんを探して提案をするそんな営業ができるということに宅配の
力を感じたわけですよ
日本で初めて宅配サービスを始めてたった一例1年足らずだったな
なんと僕たちは売上高日本一を記録してしまいます
この島根県松江市でです
全国の平均売上の3倍以上
化け物みたいなねお店をつくっちゃうわけです
多いを用意商売ってこんなに簡単なんか
っていう風にね実は若気の至りでそんなことを思ってました
ところがねそうは問屋が卸さない
たった4年でですねピークを迎えて業績は急行楽です
たくさんあったお店を売却をしてなんとかね資金繰りお金を
引っ張り出した
やりましたがついにはね息子の貯金通帳までねえ手をつける
そして錠剤稲荷神社の境内で
首を吊る木尾根探すところまで行き着くわけです
創業から8ない
時代はね少子高齢化って言った高校生
覚えていきます
僕は
宅配ノウハウを生かして
かろうじてその
復活を遂げるわけです
それまで宅配サービスそれまで雇った宅配サービスとは違って安否確認月の在宅高齢者
ベンと配食サービスというまあ正式名称ですけどね
食事の支度が困難になった高齢者や障害者に365日1日2回
安否確認をしながら弁当をては手渡しでお届けするそんな仕事です
いわば職のないぐらいです
電気ガス水道同様在宅で生きて行く為おじいちゃんおばあちゃんが生きていくために
なくてはならないねこれ社会インフラなんですね
ここで
しばれ半島の先っちょにある
美保関って街にそのせっちゃんというおばあちゃんの話をしたいと思います
彼女で3年前にとってもね仲が良かった
旦那さんに先立たれて今一人暮らしをしています
足も悪くしちゃって買い物や食事
こういった手沢ができなくなっちゃったんですね
365日1日3度の食事は僕たちがお届けをするお弁当です
せっちゃん家まではですね松江市内から片道30キロ多く60キロもあるんですね
ところがせっちゃんちゃさらにねー
入るんです何もないね曲がりくねった山道をですね15分もかけて
せっちゃんのだめにせっちゃんちの届けるたけだけダメにですねえお届けをすると当然
これね僕たち大赤字になっちゃうんですね
僕たちは民間企業です
ボランティアではありません当然お客さんで
ですからまあでもねこれもう彼ら辺は部屋から
お断りをするお客さんです
でも僕たちが食のライフラインを止めちゃうとせっちゃんは旦那さんと思い出を
いっぱい作ってきたそのお家に進めなくなってしまうんですね
さあ皆さんだったら皆さんが経営者だったらこの配色
止めますか
僕はせっちゃんの故郷を奪うことはできなかったです
まあアルミですねえ経営者としては失格かもしれません
僕たちのお弁当のお届けはた空母宅配便業者さんとは違ってですね
玄関口にとどまらないです
玄関口靴を脱いだ先に広がっている進出だとか
台所冷蔵庫の中にの中にまでだってお届けをするわけです
宅配をするおうちだっていろんなお家があります
目の前ね日本海が広がる小さな漁村の一軒家で一人暮らしをする
笑顔かわいいおばあちゃ
足が悪いのにねエレベーターの無い団地の4階に住んでいる
一人暮らしですダンディーなおじいちゃん
どこから寝床からこれ探してきたのかな
真っ赤なランド背骨背負って出てくる認知症を患ったおばあちゃ
そして僕たちは時折
冷たくなった人を発見するそんな仕事です
皆さんが
スン
そのお家のすぐそばで
僕たちは孤独死と向き合う仕事をして
僕たちの仕事は宅配だけではありません毎日顔を合わせますから
じいちゃんばあちゃんの体調の良し悪しまた微妙な心の変化
こんな所まで僕達は知っちゃうんですね
専属の宅配スタッフは誰よりも先に彼らの変化に気付くわけです
そんな重要な役割を担っています
少しでも異変があれば
これはケアマネージャーご家族はもちろん救急車だって
選んで対応します
僕たちはあくまで民間企業です
当然同時に生産性もね求められます
急いでの普通ねにね僕たちは常に先を急い
時折ないアーシュ足止めくらっちゃうんですそうです
延々と続くね雑談ですおじいちゃんおばあちゃんがこれに捕まっちゃいます
いつか必ず返ってくるからって
都会に出てったの巣子がもうここに帰って今って言うのよ
ってね僕のズボンのそう引っ張りながらねー
なく出す泣き出すおばあちゃ
は者もぬも聞こえんしゃ明日もある s へ着替えもない
早ことすんでしまいたい
ってね
岩根を毎日200おじいちゃう
宅配車両はねこうやってたくさんのお弁当を積んでお家をを回ります
代わりにこんなあり r な時にね重たい
お話をねたくさん積んで会社に帰ってきます
この10年で2倍独居高齢者は増えました
この増え続ける高齢者の中でからにね僕たちは毎日食事を届け
ちょこっとだけ声をかけることしか自分たちにできないその力不足を感じつつ
またビジネスとして成り立たないえんぺディアの配色が一体いつまでこれ続けることが
できるんだろうなーっという不安を感じているところに
アルネ大きな出来事が発生します
そうです3.11東日本大震災です
僕たちは揺れた翌日3月12日にはトラック荷台チャーターし
ありったけの食材そして水燃料
そして仲間から託されたゲーム手を積み込んでいざ東北へ迎えました
約2週間孤立した高齢者施設を中心に14カ所
食財源をして歩きました
携帯電話もつながらない電気ガス水道は当然寸断されている
食べ物もない
凍りついたガソリンスタンドには深夜から長蛇の列ができている
海外メディアは日本人は極限の状態になったって
規則正しく背教をまず
なんて言ってましたけれどもそうラってねずっと後になってからの話です
実際僕たちがトラックを入れると
奪い合い始まります
そして同号が起こりますして疑心暗鬼が埋まれていきます
もうそのね醜さは二度とこうねぇ思い出したくもないですね
これが現実です僕はここではっきり
物流が途絶えた瞬間に
すべてが狂いだすんだということを肌で感じました
陸前高田では
想像絶する光景を目の当たりにしました
それはね3 d ナビゲーション
街並みがね広がっているんですよ
だけど僕の目の前には3キロ先にある
破壊された防潮堤までがはっきり見えるですよ
すべての日本れてるんです一瞬にしてすべてを飲み込まれた
砂混じりの陸前高田の残像は衝撃的でした
つい数実前まで確実にね
ここにあった人や家家族団が思い出の場所までも
故郷が一瞬にして消えてなくなっていたわけです
そんな悲惨な光景を見ながら
ふと頭に頭をよぎったのは
意外にも僕のふるさと島根のことでした
津波で全てを奪われた陸前高田が
まるで戦後70年
経済成長で若者を茨続ける島根と重なって見えたんですね
これはやばいなぁと思いました時間がないとも思いました
すぐできることから始めようそう決めて
ありました
ふるさとを守りたい
僕にできることは一体何なんだろう
僕の使命って一体なんなんだろうな
考えました
唯一ねできることそれは一人暮らしの高齢者や障害者
まあ弱い人たちにね寄り添い続ける
これが僕たちが僕ができる唯一のことだな
そして物流が途絶えてしまった瞬間に故郷が壊れるということを僕は知ったわけです
ならば
絶対に壊れないね
ヒトモノカネ情報の流れをつくりだそうそう決めたんです
絶対に壊れない流れを作り出すために何が必要なのか
最初に入ったガッチャンコなんですよ何をがっちゃん化させるか
一つ目は仕事と仕事をがっちゃんこさせる
3.11のあとね地域氷底 npo そして行政を巻き込んで
御用聞きに彼はプロジェクトというのを始めましたこれは簡単に言えば
高齢者や障害者の皆さんのためのなんでも屋さんです
僕たちの本業は365日稼働する配食サービスです
これに次いでにできることをがちゃんとしたんです
例えばゴミばゴミゴミだし
買い物電球交換会
そしてへ
た会社のね助手席に空いてるわけだから乗っけてあげて買い物に連れてったり病院に
連れて行ったりしてあげ
本来専門の人たちがやる仕事を宅配のついでに請け負うことで費用を抑えて持続可能な
社会インフラに
するこれを目指している試みなんですね
二つ目
アイディアとアイディアのガッチャンコです
僕たちは誰しもスーパーマンじゃないんですね完璧な人なんて一人もいません
でも台に立って得意なこと
自信がある事一つくらいあるでしょうか
何だっていいんですよ別に
その違ったアイディアをですねガッチャンコすること
これでイノベーションや新しい価値を生み出す
僕は御用聞き三河屋と同時にですね地域課題解決のプラットフォーム温州し4回という
のを立ち上げています
ここには経営者はじめ公務員農家さん美容師お医者さん
大学の先生そしてこの間はねまぁた切手 u のマタギっていう職業の人たちも入って
きます
今ね多種多様な100人のメンバーが
所属してくれていますそれぞれね専門分野や
当然アイディアはまったく違うんです唯一共通するのはですね
ふるさとを守りたいっていうね
思いを持った人たちなんです
互いの強みを惜しみなく提供試合を補うことでひとりではできない
大きな社会課題に挑戦し成果を挙げつつあります
最後に
僕はビジネスの世界で成功と失敗をたくさん経験してきました
その後配色では物流の重要性
そして可能性に気がつきました
東日本大震災ここでは1-8朝
物流のもろさ故郷の故郷というものをなくすという悲しみを教えられました
故郷を守るという呼びかけに老若男女
18歳から80歳ですよ多様な100人を超える仲間が集まりました
仲間が集うことで大きな社会課題に挑戦し続ける僕は勇気をもらったんですね
もしかするとですねほんとに故郷が守り切れるんじゃないかいう希望をいただいたん
です
成熟し人口減少や地方消滅が叫ばれ新しい価値の創造ができなくなった
現代の日本に必要なことは
人と人地域と地域ビジネスとビジネスビジネスとボランティア
異質なものどうしようですねがっちゃんこさせる
1人1社1社そして一人一人その能力には限界がある
しかしそれぞれが繰り広げる小さな営みの集合体がイノベーションの卵が卵なんですよ
これが確信できます
でもね万能じゃないんです
あなたの貴重な能力な能力がアイデアを無駄にしてほしくないですね
持ち寄るんです1つ一つをつないでいくんです
つながったアイデアを組み合わせていくんですね
組み合わさった複数の集合体をさらに組み合わせてくる
例えば今まで相容れることがなかった
ビジネスとボランティアっていう世界そしてビジネスと共助というのも愛でてないです
ビジネスとまちづくりも実はマーリエと言いません
そこにはですねいろんな言い訳があるんです成立しているバックボーンの違いがあるん
じゃないかとかね
言語が合わないだとかをもうね言い訳してる場合じゃないんですよ
逃げてはいけないです互いを認め合って互いの領域を学ぶ
そしてがっちゃんこする僕はビジネスと福祉の双方の経験をしました
ビジネスとボランティア優勝と務所お金と愛
異質なもの同士を動画ちゃんこするかここにですね
持続可能な地域づくり故郷守りの実現の鍵が
きっと未来は明るいんですよ
50年後100年後も誰もが生き甲斐を感じながら生き生きと暮らすことができる地域
づくりに力を合わせていきましょう
故郷守りのプラットフォームをですね参加が求めています
今日は皆さんね僕の話を聞いてくれてありがとう
あのこれからもねみんなと一緒にね頑張っていこうと思ってますのでぜひね
一緒にやりましょう今日はありがとうございました
[拍手]